you're given an expression for the nth
partial sum of some progression and they
want you to find the general term okay
now it's really important to know I got
this question before sometimes in fact
the vast majority in progressions are
neither arithmetic nor geometric okay my
classic example of one that you guys are
very familiar with is the Fibonacci
sequence there is no common difference
between the terms in fact that's kind of
a thing the comment the difference
changes every time that's what makes the
Fibonacci sequence what it is there's
also nothing you can multiply by every
time to get from one term to the next
you immediately run into a problem when
you just have a look at the first two
terms you're like 101
so the ratio there is 1 and then the
ratio subsequently just changes every
time it's certainly not 1 so not an AP
not a GP but they can still be very well
defined and this is an example of that
so what we're going to have to try and
take advantage of is what I mentioned
with the recursive definition of a
sequence okay in terms of the partial
sum this is what we were at down before
that if you want to work out what the
nth partial sum is a way you can think
about it is as the previous partial sum
plus the next term plus the missing term
it's a little bit like saying this is
very very similar what's 5 factorial and
the answer is well it's a 4 factorial
and then you multiply it by the next
number along okay it's the same
recursive idea in fact that's why you
can see these factorials in both sides
so if I were to use that here what I'm
trying to get is actually this thing
that's what I'm after so I'm just gonna
rearrange slightly and I showed you that
this morning by subtracting s of n minus
1 from both sides that's all I'm going
to use okay if I work out what this
looks like for this particular sequence
and simplify out I will get the general
term so help me out s of n we're given s
events so that's not too hard I'm just
going to write it down as is but what is
s of n minus 1 what is the previous
partial sum what should I write down
everywhere I saw n previously I'm going
to put in n minus one it's it's actually
function notation it just isn't dressed
up like that okay so instead of writing
a seventh to the power of n I'm gonna
write a seventh ^ and minus one so I'll
have to do and then there's the take
away one hanging out on the end okay now
this does look like a bit of a mess but
you can start to see some stuffs going
to so stuffs gonna cancel right oh
that's a mistake that's better
so stuffing is going to cancel because
you see common things in both brackets
right what can you see that will cancel
yeah the negative one is going to go
because that's going to become a plus
one with the double negative so that's
really nice
you're going to get this left over now
in a real way that is the nth term like
there you go there's an expression okay
so in some ways you're finished but we
can't simplify this right think back to
your to unit your knowledge of index
laws and that kind of thing what could I
do with this that might help any
suggestion okay so look I've got these
are just bases common bases with powers
right I'm not multiplying them so I'm
not going to add indices or anything
like that but I can do something to make
this a little more helpful what I'm
gonna write out is if you think about it
what's the difference between these
what's the difference between these this
is seven lots of this where do I get
that right or is it one over seven
months it's one over seven months one
over seven right because think about
this right from index laws I can go from
this to this
I'm used to going in the other direction
when you multiply numbers you add their
indices but if I can do that I can just
as easily break this apart into two
pieces
do you agree now if that is true then
now I have a common factor right so
that's one option I could have taken I
don't like this option so much because
what you get is not something in terms
of n you get everything in terms of n
minus one so instead of writing
this way even though it's just as
equally true I'm gonna muck around with
this guy instead okay I'm gonna leave
the first fraction like so and I'm going
to adjust this and say well that's seven
lots of one on seven to be in to the end
do you see what I've done it's a bit
weird because this is this is actually a
seventh to the power of negative one
I'm say that again a seventh to the
power of negative one that's why the
indices add up but I why would I write
that with a fraction and a negative
index I might as well write a whole
number so I've got one of them over here
and I'm taking away seven of them this
is just algebra right can you collect
like - Sami how many will I have overall
it'll be negative six of this object
which is a seventh and does that make
sense
so you need to use some of your index
law stuff which is going to come up on
what because every time you do these
general terms these powers are going to
go up quite frequently especially with
GPS okay